this video is brought to you by morning
brew
hi welcome to today's episode of cold
fusion
before i start this episode isn't a
recommendation to buy any of apple's
products
in fact i'm a windows and android user
myself
the following is simply my documentation
of what i perceive to be the biggest
moment in computing history in the last
decade or so
i think it's just fascinating so make
sure you're comfortable for this one
get out the popcorn and be ready to be
entertained or learn a thing or two
you are watching tv
[Music]
it seems that everyone hates apple these
days and there's some rationale for that
recently they've made their products
impossible to repair
increased prices of their products and
accessories to a ridiculous level
and enjoy excessive control but what if
apple
actually did something to push the
industry forward and spur competition
well it turns out that they may just
have done that
phones and computers are never seen as
comparable when it comes to power
they both live in different worlds
though as long time
subscribers would know back in 2012 i
was comparing the two of them
and seeing if a phone could replace a pc
the rate at which phone power was
improving year over year
was absolutely unbelievable to me at the
time those were some fun days
the main difference between phones and
desktop computers
is that they use different types of
processor technology
phones use a type of processor design
called arm
while desktop computers generally use
another type called x86
like intel for example arm
is a simpler design than x86 making it
more efficient
but x86 traditionally used to be able to
do more
but this is changing the interesting
thing to note
is that in recent years our phones have
been getting faster
at a much more rapid rate than computers
have been improving
so here's a question what happens when
the chips in our phones come close to
the power of laptop and desktop
computers
what if you took this amazing
performance and efficiency of a mobile
chip
and put it in the body of a laptop that
is
access to a larger battery and more
space to breathe
well things that many thought were
impossible begin to happen
and then i didn't plug it in for four
days
totaling a little over 10 hours of mixed
use
and still had 17 percent less animations
are buttery smooth as you'd expect
and even opening and closing some of
those bigger apps like chrome and
lightroom
are just as fast if not faster than on
my desktop which is sick it's just an
overall
really responsive feel okay look at this
guy
okay angelica when you're editing this
show the footage from the surface pro
x uh how that was the windows version of
this
there was extreme lag moving and doing
anything and here it is extremely smooth
and this is the base model macbook air
without
a fan these m1 macs are setting up
the future of mac hardware as we know it
is changing
everything the new macbooks
and the m1 chip that powers it resulted
in an energy efficient chip
as powerful as some desktop cpus
what most people are missing is that
this isn't an ordinary macbook
the m1 chip represents the culmination
of a decade of planning
and a radical shift in the consumer
computing industry
on the surface putting a mobile chip in
apple's best-selling computer
seems really stupid but when you look
deeper
it makes a whole lot of sense as you'll
see later
it's actually a classic case of
disruption as defined
by clay christensen in 1997.
so how did apple do this well the
journey of how apple got to this point
will be the subject of today's episode
you will also see how intel's ceo
refused to work on the iphone
and made one of the biggest mistakes in
tech history
to truly understand what apple has done
we first must go through some quick
history
central processing units or cpus are the
brain of computers
they do all the billions of calculations
a second to make our devices run
cpus run on what are called instructions
these are the fundamental tiny bits of
data that tell our computers what to do
for example add these two numbers
together fetch this number from memory
that kind of thing when you group these
commands together
they're called an instruction set in the
emerging battle between mobile and
desktop cpus
it would be the variations in how these
instruction sets were handled that would
make
all the difference since its founding in
by robert noyce and gordon moore intel
has been the gatekeeper of mainstream
computer cpus
they would gain the name x86 after a
series of popular chips
in the late 70s and early 80s that ended
in the number 86
the x86 instruction set architecture
would go on to dominate the industry
from the 1980s chip manufacturers would
begin to add
more and more complicated instructions
to be perceived as better to a
non-suspecting buyer
over time these instructions made the
chip's functionality bloated
precious and limited physical space on
the chip was being taken up by fancy
instructions
that were hardly ever used by the rest
of the system
meanwhile in the uk in 1983
a company by the name of acorn computers
decided to go down a different path
instead of making things more and more
complicated why not take a simpler
approach
this mode of thinking was called risk a
reduced instruction set computing
as opposed to the bloated sisk from
companies like intel
some people are saying risk technology
is the wave of the future other people
are saying risk is already a passe
technology what does this expert think
well stuart the
current ibm pc line that they're based
upon a processor called the 8086. it's
kind of a messy architecture
so risk gives us as a new starting point
we can say okay here's a
simpler instruction set faster less code
space well if you talk about risk is
that a philosophy a way you design
a machine architecture or is it a
specific set of instructions
it certainly is a philosophy or a style
and in fact it's a style which differs
depending on what you're trying to do
the main idea is not to add any
complexity to the machine
unless it pays for itself by how
frequently you would use it
out of this came the acorn risk machine
project
otherwise known as arm this was the
birth of the type of chips that would be
used in all of our smartphones in the
coming decades
so in this episode for simplicity's sake
we'll just refer to wrist chips as
simplified cpus
and cisc chips as complex cpus
while developing the first arm chip
during testing
something unexpected happened here
professor steve ferber
speaks about how he started the arm
project
as we set about designing the arm
we didn't really expect to pull it off
okay firstly we thought this risk idea
is so obvious
that big industry will pick up on it and
will get trampled underfoot
we expected to go into this project
finding out why it wasn't a good idea to
do it
and the and the obstacle just never
emerged from the mist we just kept
moving forward through the fog until
eventually we had a fully working arm
chip in our hands
i don't think it was day one but a few
days later we decided we'd better
measure the power consumption so i
turned the arm chip on
ran some and some code on it looked at
the ammeter
and it was reading zero and i knew we
designed a fairly low power chip but
this was
um a bit remarkable and it turned out
that actually i'd
in inserting the ammeter into the power
supply i'd failed to connect the power
supply
and so no current was flowing through
the ammeter but the chip was still
running
so hang on so it wasn't just you didn't
connect the ammeter it was actually that
you didn't connect the chip to the power
supply yes
there was no power supply connection to
the chip and yet he was running
by 1985 they had their first prototype
and by 1987 the first computer based on
arm was produced
the acorn archimedes and from here
arm would license its designs to other
manufacturers for them to build
at first being low power was a nice side
effect
but it didn't have much of an advantage
for desktop machines
but as portable computing devices
started showing up
arm became the first choice they were
used in everything from nokias to
ericsson phones
so how are these arm chips so efficient
[Music]
when we talk about computer cpus we
measure them in gigahertz
and that means clock cycles per second
simplified cpus
such as arm generally will do one simple
instruction per clock cycle
while desktop chips may use many cycles
to complete one complex instruction
this means more power consumption less
efficiency
and more heat produced multiply this by
hundreds of millions of times a second
and the issue starts to become clear in
some
desktop cpus some of the complex
instructions can take a dozen clock
cycles or more to complete
though contrary to popular belief both
kinds of processes were flourishing
during the 1990s
in the early days simple instruction set
designs were great for engineering and
graphics
so much so that computers using the
technology helped create films
such as jurassic park toy story and more
simple instruction cpus were also used
in the 3d graphics chip of the nintendo
and other early game consoles but the
desktop market
safely belonged to intel this symbol
outside says inside you'll find a legacy
of technological leadership
the intel pentium processor
for the next generation of compatible
power
that's intel the computer inside
[Music]
in 1991 apple ibm and motorola combined
forces to create the power pc chip
interestingly powerpc was a desktop
chip but used simple instruction sets
apple would proudly put them in their
computers during the 90s
the simple instruction arm cpu would get
a huge boost in the form of the ipod in
apple's use of the arm chip and the ipod
was a microcosm for arm's popularity in
portable devices
from mobile phones to mp3 players by
there were 1 billion arm chips and
devices
despite using arms simple cpus and their
portable devices
apple's power pc collaboration with ibm
and motorola
wasn't going so well their simple cpus
were falling behind
intel it was looking like intel and
their complex cpu way of thinking
was the way to go for the desktop market
so apple
left powerpc behind and yes
it's true
we are going to begin the transition
from the power pc
to intel processors when intel signed
the deal with apple in 2005
apple was already thinking of what comes
next
they went to intel to see if they could
power the upcoming iphone
now at this time a moment occurred that
intel
would never forget paul ottolini ceo of
intel at the time
didn't see such a deal working out as it
was far outside their speciality
he didn't believe that intel could earn
enough money by building mobile chips
for apple's new iphone
revenue wasn't going to cover the
research costs or so he thought
he couldn't imagine the iphone selling
well this obviously proved to be a huge
missed opportunity
the iphone launched in 2007 using a
simple instruction arm cpu
if intel's ceo paul ottolini had made
the deal happen they would have had a
massive stake in the iphone business
but unfortunately for intel apple was
moving on
without them in 2008
apple would sign an architecture license
with arm this was so
they could design their own chips from
the ground up
they would also buy pa semi a company
whose founder
previously specialized in high
performance arm chip development
this was a key strategic acquisition for
apple
it gave them the expertise and potential
to design
some of the best arm chips and put them
on the road to disrupt intel and their
x86 processors
in 2012 apple releases their first fully
custom designed cpu
it would be code named swift and was
used in the iphone 5.
this was in contrast to using
off-the-shelf designs from arm as they
had previously done
this new apple built chip was two times
as fast as the previous chip
even for being a first generation chip
it had impressive performance when
compared to the mobile competition
but it wasn't head-turning the real
shock to the industry came the next year
in 2013 with the apple a7 in the iphone
5s
apple's early adoption of a 64-bit
architecture
stunned everybody they even beat arm's
own cpu teams by more than a year
arm's own 64-bit design wouldn't be seen
until late 2014
in the form of the galaxy s4
apple famously called their 2013 chip
design
quote desktop class architecture most
people
thought it was just apple bragging but
this wording actually was a hidden clue
as to where the company was heading as
you'll soon see
their latest custom chip does actually
hold up with desktop pcs
by 2014 there were 50 billion arm chips
in the world
all the while apple kept selling a bunch
of iphones and making a heap of money
and do you know what all of this revenue
you can buy
a ton of r d the chips inside of the
iphone kept evolving and improving
getting faster while using less power
by the end of 2018 with apple's a12 chip
it was looking like apple was catching
up to intel
in this chart the grey dots are apple
and the blue squares are intel
in the past five years intel managed to
increase their flagship performance by
about 28 percent
in the same time apple managed to
improve their designs by 300
and this is where things start getting
very strange
the intel chip at the top of this chart
the core i9
10900k is a desktop chip that uses 125
watts of power
it's the kind that you have to plug into
a wall
meanwhile apple's a14 chip in the iphone
the one in the top right hand corner
that performs better than the chip i
just mentioned
uses 5 watts and is powered by a phone
battery
youtuber jonathan morrison does a test
of exporting a heavy duty video file
on a desktop versus an iphone 12. check
this out
this is a fairly capable machine it's a
10 core it's got a beefy gpu
and what i have here is sony fx9 hdr
10-bit footage
we're going to start that i'm going to
throw this open
we're gonna see a couple of things right
we're gonna see the cpu cores just spike
up and you should start hearing the fans
now in the meantime while this thing is
chugging along
i have the iphone 12 mini little guy
keep in mind this thing is still slowly
chugging along i'm going to open up
imovie
create a movie the first thing you
notice is just the scrubbing in the
playback right so this is a fanless
teeny tiny iphone 12 and
just butter so what i'm going to do is
take that
export make sure we're in 4k
on 20 battery hdr
keep in mind this thing's still going
it's got a nice little head start right
so this is on a battery about 20 left
no fan and this is a decked out imac
the thing to note here is that the
iphone chip does have hardware
acceleration but it can be argued that
this is just a smarter way of doing
things anyway
the m1 chip is even faster than this
looking at this and the speed at which
apple's chip performance was
accelerating
apple pretty much was forced to ditch
intel and their x86 platform
intel was just too slow to innovate they
were struggling to keep up with the
manufacturing technology
whereas apple could outsource
manufacturing of their custom arm
designs to others like samsung
the performance lead of intel's desktop
cpus were being evaporated
right in front of everyone's eyes
by 2019 the ipad was more powerful than
the intel macbook pro of the previous
year
this is something i mentioned in a
previous episode
the speed of all of these advancements
would come back to shock people in 2020
if you're interested in this episode so
far you might be keen on some more tech
news
from today's sponsor morningbrew apple
has announced that from the 1st of
january they'll be lowering their app
store fees
from 30 to 15 this is in response to the
anti-trust allegations from the united
states and eu
apple has also agreed to pay 113 million
dollars
for its scandal in slowing down old
iphones to make their batteries last
longer
that's chump change if you ask me i came
to know these stories through morning
brew
a great way to catch up on news in the
morning you can get up to speed in just
5 minutes instead of wasting time going
to different sources
it's informative and makes news less dry
and boring
it gets sent to your inbox each weekday
and saturday and it's free
so there's no reason not to subscribe to
morning brew if you're interested in
business
finance or tech click the link in the
description below to sign up to morning
brew
it only takes 15 seconds
alright so where were we arm chips are
being used for low power users
like in mobile phones intel refused to
make chips for the iphone
and then apple decided to do it
themselves by acquiring a company
and then with this expertise apple has
pushed the state of the art forward
until mobile phone chips were comparable
to pcs
and now it was time for arm and apple to
take on the pc
head on in november of 2020
apple reveals its new processor to take
on the pc
it's called the m1 the company's first
custom cpu
designed with max in mind it features 16
billion transistors
35 more than the a14 inside the new
iphone 12
and because it's arm-based and shares
the same dna as the iphone
the new macbook can run ipad and iphone
apps all with transistors on a five
nanometer process
early testing of the chip is blowing the
online tech reviewer community off their
feet
proceeded to annihilate the other tests
posting 1744
on single core which is faster than
every intel mac
ever made now badeem really wants to
jump in
uh in front of the camera and give his
opinion all right so i have a 2018
base 15-inch macbook pro i tried playing
league of legends
it's not smooth it's glitchy you get
dropped frames
and i'm just blown away that we're
getting native resolution everything
maxed out
getting around 60 fps and you have a
dedicated graphics card
in that yes it has a dedicated chip and
this is under rosetta
not even optimized it's not even
optimized for apple silicon
these are legit this is super fast
to the point where i had a friend he
actually makes an app a pretty well
known app he uses a hackintosh
3950x 16 core really decked out system
specifically for development right this
is his build time
somehow these m1 devices are keeping up
one of them being
fanless it's pretty crazy and this was
the moment like when i got the numbers
back i was like
this is this is real apple silicon is
real
if apple as a company is to continue on
their current performance trajectory
it's going to be insane to see here's a
quote from anandatech
quote apple claims the m1 to be the
fastest cpu in the world
given our data on the older a14 beating
all of intel's designs
and just falling short of amd's newest
zen 3 chips
we can certainly believe that apple and
the m1 will be able to achieve that
claim
amd has shown lots of progress lately
however
it'll be incredibly hard to catch up
with apple's power efficiency
if apple's performance trajectory
continues at this pace the x86
performance crown
might never be regained end quote
when you are aware of the wider
applications of arm in the real world
it was only a matter of time the fastest
supercomputer in the world
the japanese fugaku is three times
faster than ibm's
and it uses arm architecture though this
is the clincher
needing a more powerful computer isn't
relevant to everyone
but having more efficiency and less
power consumption is
and it's something that everyone can
notice
clay christensen who wrote the book
innovator's dilemma in 1997
states that disruptive innovations quote
involve no new technologies
rather they consist of components built
around proven technologies that are put
together in novel architectures
offering the consumer a set of
attributes never before available
and he goes on they are quote
initially used only by the
unsophisticated consumers of the low end
markets
so arm chips have existed since the
1980s
but in the current day they've
traditionally only been used for lower
end items
like smartphones for example though
putting arm chips in a laptop
has existed for a long time windows has
done this for years
but having an arm chip that is so
powerful that it can reach the top end
of the consumer computer market
is new christiansen who wrote this quote
shows a chart of disruptive technologies
25 years ago
look carefully at this what does it look
like
steve jobs even had something to say
about this
speaking at the launch of his next
computer he said
that all systems and architectures have
about 10 years of life
at the start you have to get people to
build applications for it and around
year five
it reaches its architectural peak quote
then it goes on what you might call a
glide slope
the architecture is everything it's
going to ever be at that point
so what about program compatibility well
according to earlier reviews
the cpu is so powerful that it has
similar or better performance
running apps that weren't even designed
for it
according to the verge it's so good that
they couldn't even tell if the apps
running were coded for
arm or not
so in conclusion despite no upgradable
ram
a hefty upgrade price and no external
gpu support
the big story here is the chip
architecture and nothing else
it's proving that arm can have an
inherent advantage in the laptop and
desktop space
this moment was decades in the making i
feel honored to have been around to
witness it
things are going to get super
interesting from here on out
and i can only hope that competition
arises from this moment
this is so us as consumers can win
though it's strange how there are those
out there who get upset over this
can't we just enjoy the progress that's
being made instead of ridiculing each
other over our technology preferences
i'm just happy that the technology is
moving and competition may come from it
this performance increase is the biggest
gap that we've seen in many many years
and i think it's awesome and that's the
end of the story
so thanks for watching are you guys
excited for future laptops that have
extremely long battery life
and have the cpu power of desktops these
kinds of machines can be less expensive
and do wonders for students and
professionals alike
anyway that's it from me i do want to
make a quick mention that i've got some
new merch
just in time for the holiday season so
if you're feeling festive
you can pick some up in the description
below anyway my name is dagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
um
[Music]
you